what is tic-tac-toe what are we talking
about and then um right what how how is
it designed right so so
you've got you've got a three by three
grid and each
each
each could be in three states it can be
empty or it can have an x or an o yeah
all right so three to the ninth
is a uh well what is
how big is it i should know
um but it's 80
81 times 81 times three so
um
anyway
eight is like two to the third and so
that would be
uh that would be like two to the sixth
um
and then uh but that would be 64 then
you have to anyway i love how you're
doing the calculation so
anyway the three comes from the fact
that it's either empty an x or an o
right
and
the 650 what was it was a machine that
had only
uh
2 000
10 digit words
you go from zero zero zero zero to one
nine nine nine and that's it
and and in each word you have a ten
digit number
so that's not many bits i mean i i gotta
have three
in order to have a memory of every
position i've seen
i need three to the ninth bits
uh
okay but it was a decimal machine too it
didn't have bits but but it did have
effect it did have
strange instruction
where if if you had a tentative number
that but all the digits were either
eight or nine
uh yeah you'd be eight nine nine eight
eight or something like that that would
uh you you could make a test whether it
was eight or nine that was one of the
strange things ibm engineers put into
to the machine i have no idea what well
um
i hardly ever use but anyway i i needed
one digit for every
every position i'd seen
zero meant it was a bad position i meant
it was good position
i i think i started out at five or six
you know but if you if you win a game
then you uh
then you increase the value of that
position for you but you decrease it
for
for your opponent uh
uh so but but i i i could
i had that much total memory for every
every possible position was one digit
and i had a total of 20 000 digits
which had which had to also include my
program yes and all the logic and
everything including how to
how to ask
the user what the moves are and things
like this okay so so i think i had to
work it out get every every position in
tic-tac-toe
it is equivalent to to roughly eight
others because you you you can rotate
the board
um
which gives you a factor four and you
can also flip it over and that's another
factor too so so i might you know so i
might have needed only three to the
ninth over eight positions you know plus
plus a little bit
uh so i had but anyway that was
that was a a part of the program to to
squeeze it into this tiny
so you tried to find an efficient
representation that took account for
that kind of rotation i had to otherwise
i couldn't do the learning
uh wow so so but but i had three parts
to my tic-tac-toe program
uh and i called it brain one brain two
and brain three
so brain one
just played
a um
um let's see
at random
okay
it's your turn okay you got to put an x
somewhere it has to go in an empty space
but that's that's it okay
choose
choose one and and
uh
brain two
had a canned routine
and i think it was it also
maybe it had
maybe to assume you were the first
player or maybe it allowed you to be
first i think you were allowed to be
either first a second but had a canned
built-in strategy known to be optimum
for tic-tac-toe
[Music]
before i forget by the way uh i learned
uh many years later that charles babbage
had had planned to
had thought about programming
tic-tac-toe for his
uh for his dream machine that he that he
was never able to finish wow so that was
the program he thought about more than a
hundred years ago yeah
he did that okay
and i had but and and i had however been
influenced by a
demonstration at the at the museum of
science and industry in chicago it's
like it's like boston's science museum i
think bell labs had had prepared a
special exhibit about
telephones and relay technology and they
had a tic-tac-toe playing
machine as part of that exhibit so that
had been one of my
uh you know something i'd seen before i
was a freshman in college and and
inspired me to see if i could write a
program for
okay so so anyway i had brain one
random
you know uh
knowing nothing brain two knowing
everything and then brain three was the
learning one
and and i could
i i could play
brain one against brain one brain one
against brain two and so on and so uh
you could also play against the user
against the live universe but but but uh
so i started going the learning thing
and i said okay you know take two random
random people
just playing
uh
tic-tac-toe uh
knowing nothing
and after about i forget the number now
but but it converged after about 600
games uh
to a safe draw
the way
my program learned was actually it
learned how not to make mistakes because
you know how to
it didn't try to do anything
for winning it just tried to do yeah
drop news and not lose so that was
probably because of the way i did i
designed the learning thing i could have
you know
had a different
uh reinforcement function that would
that would reward brilliant play but
anyway it didn't
and uh and and if if i took a novice
against the uh
you know the skilled player uh it it was
able to learn uh how to play a good game
so that was that and that was really
mike
but after i finished that i i felt i i
understood programming
was there um
[Music]
did you
did a curiosity and interest in learning
systems persist for you
so
why why did you want brain three to
learn
yeah i i think naturally it's
we're talking about rod brooks
he was teaching all kinds of
very small devices
to to learn stuff
if a leaf drops off of a tree uh
you know
he was saying something well it learns
if there's wind or not
but but i i mean he pushed that a little
bit too far but
he said he could probably train some
little mini bugs to to scour out dishes
if he had enough
financial support i don't know
can i can i ask you about that because
um
he he also mentioned that during
those years
there was discussion about
inspired by touring about computation
you know of what is computation
yeah
and
you know i never thought about any stuff
like that that was
that that was way
to fill us up i mean
i i was a
i was a freshman
after all i mean
i i didn't
i was pretty much a machine
so it's almost like yeah i got you it's
a tinkering mindset uh not a
philosophical mindset
it was just exciting to me to uh to be
able to control something but not
but not
but not to say hmm am i solving a big
problem or something like that or is is
this a step for humankind or anything no
no way
when did you first start thinking about
computation in the big sense
you know like the universal turing
machine well
i i mean i had to pass an ex i
i had to take i had to take uh
classes on
computability when i was a senior
so you know we read this book by martin
davis and
yeah this is cool stuff but you know i i
learned about it because i know i needed
to pass the exams but i didn't
i didn't invent any of that forward
stuff but i i had great fun playing with
the machine you know i
um i wrote program because it was fun to
write programs and
and
and get
this
i i mean it was like watching miracles
happen
you